Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Java language as
Spanish creole.
In fact,
the only Spanish based Creole language
in Asia.
The name of the language comes from the
Spanish word Shabacado,
meaning vulgar or in poor taste.
That's because [inaudible] was
originally considered incorrect or
corrupted.
Spanish Java Condo is spoken in the
Philippines and as a direct result of
the Philippines history as a Spanish
colony.
It's not spoken by the majority of
Filipinos,
but by a minority living in specific
areas.
It spoken in different varieties in
Cavita,
a province just south of Metro Manila in
Cotabato on the island of Mindanao,
Basilan island to the south of Mindanao,
and it's spoken by the largest number of
speakers in Zamboanga,
especially in Zamboanga City on
Mindanao.
It's notoriously difficult to find
consistent statistics about the number
of Java speakers,
but according to the United Nations
statistics division in 2005,
there were 431,000
native speakers,
including around 311,000
in Zamboanga.
But those numbers underestimate the
number of people who speak Java.
Condo zone belonged to a city,
a city with over a million people is a
very diverse place with migrants from
all over the Philippines and Java.
Camo serves as the most common Lingua
Franca.
So hundreds of thousands more people
speak it as a second or third language.
So what is it exactly?
Is it Spanish?
Well,
not exactly.
It's a Spanish based creole,
meaning that Spanish is the lexus fire
language,
the language that supplied most of the
vocabulary while the grammar is largely
based on Filipino languages,
like the science to catalog and guy
known the Spanish colonial period.
And the Philippines began in 15,
21 and beginning in 15,
65,
the Philippine islands began to be
administered from the vice royalty of
new Spain,
which was based in Mexico City.
This continued until Mexico's
independence in 18,
21 after which the Philippines were
administered directly by Spain,
but for those 256 years,
Philippines had significant interaction
with new Spain and it's people during
this time,
the Philippines and new Spain.
We're connected by the galleon trade,
large trading ship voyages that made the
journey between Manila Acapulco once or
twice a year.
This brought Filipinos in contact with
Spanish speaking workers from new Spain
while soldiers and settlers from Spain
were present.
Soldiers and settlers from new span also
arrived in significant numbers.
One place where many newcomers settled
wasn't assemble under which the Spanish
seized in 16,
35 in an attempt to stop attacks by
morrow pirates,
they established a fortress called at a
Alpharetta.
They San Jose Royal Court of St Joseph.
The population of this fort had a direct
impact on the development of the avocado
spoken in Zamboanga.
There were Visayan warriors from say boo
and other areas,
Spanish soldiers,
including those from Spain,
Mexico,
as well as Peru and Jesuit priests who
served Spanish translators and might
have taught the others how to
communicate,
resulting in a pigeon language that
would become the travel condo creole.
This fort was eventually abandoned,
but some of the population remained and
continued to interact with locals while
the Jesuit priests continued their
conversion efforts.
This both spread Java condo and brought
additional influences to the language
making it a little more Filipino and a
little less Spanish.
This is the kind of contact that
resulted in the creation of other forms
of Java condo as well,
but the exact influences were somewhat
different.
For example,
the Java condo spoken and covey tape has
more Castilian,
Spanish influence and less Mexican
Spanish influence and has more Tagalog
influence rather than be cited.
Now let's look at some features of
avocado and see how it differs from
Spanish.
I'm focusing mainly on Zumba on Daniel,
that Java condo creole spoken in
Zamboanga.
We'll start by focusing on the syntax
and I'll introduce additional elements
as we go.
While Spanish is generally Svo,
Java,
Camo is generally vso like Tagalo or
resign.
Here's the sentence,
meaning the men looked at Jose in
Spanish in middle,
and in Java,
O'connell in Spanish,
the subject alone comes first,
but in Java condo it comes after the
verb.
There are some other important things we
can notice about the sentence.
The verb,
middle from Merdod means look in
Spanish,
while in Java it means both look and
see,
so depending on the intended meaning,
the Spanish translation might be
elluminate br plus a using a different
verb to mean.
See,
also notice that the verb forms are
slightly different.
The Spanish verb is conjugated for the
third person,
singular conjugation in the Predator it
or past historic tents,
but Java Kennel verbs are conjugated at
all.
The verb.
Madonna will be the same for any
subject.
The only thing that can change is this
extra little piece right here,
which is a proverb that shows tents.
Yeah,
indicates past top,
indicates present,
and I indicates future.
These are not always used but can be
used for clarity and for emphasis.
Also,
notice that Java condo uses Khan instead
of our column,
comes from the Spanish word con,
meaning with,
but in Java Kunle it's used as the
object or accusative marker,
so already we can see a number of
differences between Spanish and Chava
condo.
Another example,
here's a sentence,
meaning you teach children,
you being the plural form.
In Spanish,
we'll status and Nina's and in Java
connell the insignia that again in
Spanish,
the subject comes first and the Java
condo.
It comes after the verb and you'll
notice the present tense verb,
top before the verb now is a locomotive
particle or preposition which shows
direction or location.
Apparently it comes from a historian and
note the difference in vocabulary for
the words meaning children in Java
Kunle,
you'll see the phrase Monga Manga is a
plural marker found in Tagalo,
Visayan and Haley Guy Known in Java
candle.
This is sometimes used as the plural
marker and the Spanish plural form with
s or s is sometimes used.
Another example.
Here's the sentence,
meaning I love you in Spanish or the
ammo and the Java Kunle on my ego or
that my yield,
but indego this time,
the Spanish sentence is Sov,
not Svo,
because when the object is a pronoun,
it usually comes before the verb,
but in Spanish,
the subject pronouns can be dropped
because the person in number are clear
from the conjugation of the verb.
In Java,
however,
verbs are conjugated,
so the subject Pronoun is necessary and
notice that the top is optional.
Earlier we saw that cone meaning with in
Spanish is used as the object marker in
Java candle here,
Contigo,
which means with you in Spanish,
is used as the object Pronoun.
All of the subject pronouns of Spanish
origin have an object pronoun equivalent
like this that begins with colon.
There are other subject pronouns of
Filipino origin and their corresponding
object.
Pronouns are also a Filipino origin.
Some pronouns might come from Filipino
languages because they communicate
something that the Spanish pronouns
couldn't communicate.
Notice,
for example,
the first person,
plural pronouns come in and Kita,
which come from Visayan,
some Austronesian languages,
including some languages of the
Philippines.
Distinguished between the first person,
plural,
inclusive of the listener and exclusive
of the listener.
Another example,
here's a sentence,
meaning this is Pablo.
In Spanish,
it's the low and in Java candle again,
in Spanish,
the subject comes first.
It's the demonstrative Pronoun.
Sdi.
In Chicago it comes after the predicate
and you can see that the pronoun is
abbreviated,
but it's not always so there's actually
no verb in this sentence because Java
condo has no copy Copula,
so the word order is really predicate
subject.
The word see is a subject marker for
personal names,
which is also found in Tagalog and
healy,
guy known in Spanish.
Demonstrative pronouns have gender,
but Java cundall has no grammatical
gender.
So for a female name in Spanish it would
be like this is that is Trisha with a
change in the pronouns.
While then Sheva Condo,
it would be this with no change in the
Pronoun and other elements of the world
order that is different is that
adjectives come before nouns.
In Java candle,
not after.
In Spanish we have limited meaning free
time,
and in Java we have another sentence.
Here's the sentence,
meaning I love their house in Spanish,
you almost,
and in Java Kunle again,
notice that in the Spanish sentence you
can drop the subject,
but in Java condo you can't.
The third person,
plural,
possessive pronoun in Java is de la.
The possessive pronouns typically
consist of d prefix to the beginning of
the Spanish subject,
pronouns,
or to Filipino clinic pronouns.
Another sentence,
here's the sentence,
meaning Helena or Jane bought a second
dog in Spanish.
Why not?
And in Java one pro one,
you've got those battle.
Again,
we see the SVO versus vsl.
We see the subject Marker C and a pre
verb in Java Condo,
and we see the word for dog.
There's one new thing to notice here.
The ordinal numbers in Spanish is
Segundo,
but in Java condo it's eco dose.
The cardinal numbers of Java Convo,
like those are all basically the same as
in Spanish,
but with slightly different spelling,
but while Spanish has different forms
for ordinal numbers,
Shavano,
prefixes,
eco to cardinal numbers,
notice that the Spanish ordinal number
pretty metal is used,
and other Spanish ones can be used in
place of the Cheva Council forums to
say,
good window for example.
Now let's look at a couple more
sentences and see what we find.
Here's the sentence,
meaning the book will be published in
five languages in Spanish and thinker,
the almost word for word,
it's the book will be published in five
languages,
and in Java Kunle word for word,
it's the book verbal prefix come out in
five language.
In this sentence,
we see that the subject comes first in
both sentences,
in Java,
Connell,
Svo,
word order is possible.
For example,
it's often found a new stories that are
translated from Spanish media keeping
the text as similar to the Spanish
version as possible.
Another thing is that in Chicago there's
no passive form,
so passive meaning is understood from
context or the action can be paraphrased
in Spanish.
The sentence is explicitly future,
but the traveler Kennel sentence doesn't
have the future Prevar I it can have it,
but here it doesn't.
We see here that the verb is proceeded
by mom.
Mom is a prefix that makes a verb
distributive,
meaning that the action is performed by
several subjects or on several objects
separately.
Here,
the book will be released separately
five different times in five different
versions,
so money is used to show the
distribution of the action among the
different releases of the book.
Mine is also a prefix that can be
attached to nouns and English loan words
to turn them into travel.
Kennel verbs,
Mung translate,
Mon Picnic,
Monroe reply,
etc.
There's a similar prefix mug into
kellogg and visayan and notice that the
word for languages in spanish is easy
omas,
while in java condo it's lingala.
Hey,
in java,
connell,
and oTher languages of the Philippines,
lingua here is used to refer to
languages that are spoken by communities
of people while in spanish language
refers more to the general concept of
language,
so to refer to a specific human language
and spanish.
Mom is the typical word and one last
sentence.
This sentence means they left without
paying for the drink in spanish,
so if we don't have either word for
word,
it's reflexive particle.
They went without pay the drink in java.
Candle light,
but gobbled nana word for word.
It's past tense.
Pre-verbal leave.
They without pay object marker.
Definite article,
alcoholic drink.
This last sentence is fairly different
from it.
Spanish equivalent first,
notice that the verbs are different.
in spanish,
we see the reflexive form of the verb.
Eod meaning to go.
The reflexive form is used to mean
leave.
Java.
Camo doesn't have this construction,
so another verb has used.
Instead it's a derivative of the spanish
word,
salyer meaning to go out.
See,
la is the third person plural,
subject pronouns,
which comes from tagalog and visayan.
Hawaii is a negative pre verb for the
past tense.
Cornell is a combination of con,
the object marKer plus l,
the definite article.
Finally we have the word tomato,
which means alcoholic drink in java
candle.
Well,
in spanish it's maybe the java candle
also has a similar word baby,
but that is a general word for a drink,
not specifically an alcoholic drink.
Before I mentioned that java was
influenced by mexican spanish,
there was undoubtedly some influence on
the pronunciation of mcconnell in
travel.
Kennel also contains some vocabulary
that clearly came from mexican spanish,
for example,
psychotic meaning grass.
This is originally a word from now what
to an indigenous language of Mexico.
It entered mexican spanish as a lone
word and then entered jaVa kennel via
mexican spanish.
These words are also from now what'll
John Gay meaning market which comes from
young gay jungle,
meaning monkey from jungle and
commentate meaning sweet potato.
There were other words and expressions
that don't come from the wattle words,
but are common to Mexico and maybe have
special usage in Mexico.
In Mexico,
when you want someone to repeat
something because you didn't catch what
they said,
you ask monday.
This is also used in java o'connell.
I also hear that a lot of swear words or
of specifically mexican origin,
but I'll skip those for now.
So our avocado and spanish mutually
intelligible,
well,
yes and no.
Some java speakers have told me that
they can understand around 60 percent or
more of certain varietieS of spanish in
particular european,
spanish and mexican spanish,
but this is not necessarily true fOr
spanish speakers who here java
o'connell,
while most java connell speakers are
familiar with the word order of english
and maybe the word order of spanish
itself.
Spanish speakers are generally not
familiar with the word order of filipino
languages like tagalog or scion,
so when they hear cheva condo,
they might just hear a mishmash of
spanish words,
but be confused by how they're being put
together in sentences.
This is especially true for informal
travel condo which has more influence
from filipino languages where as formal
travel economy is closer to spanish,
but probably with some basic exposure to
the grammar,
they could improve their comprehension
of it quite quickly.
Some people argue that [inaudible]
really isn't that different from other
filipino languages like to gallo or
scion,
which contain a lot of spanish
vocabulary themselves.
Java condo just has a lot more of it.
The question of the day for spanish
speakers,
how well can you understand java candle?
I'll leave a link to a video in the
description for you to see before
commenting if you want,
and for java speakers,
how weLl can you understand spanish?
Does it depend on the variety of spanish
or on the context?
Be sure to follow lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram,
especially instagram because it's the
coolest,
and once again,
I'd like to say thank you to all of my
patreon supporters,
especially these ones right here on the
screen who are my top tier patrion
supporters.
Many tHanks to them and to you.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.